왜 그게 흥미롭거나 중요한지 표면적으로 바로 명확하지 않더라도 괜찮아요. 실제로 밀도 행렬에 대해 추론할 때 이 사실을 매우 자주 사용하고,
주어진 밀도 행렬을 이런 방식으로 표현하는 것이 그것을 더 잘
이해하고 싶을 때 종종 맨 처음 하는 것이에요. 예시를 보여줄게요. 이전에 나왔던 밀도 행렬을 떠올려 보세요. 각각 확률 1/2로
0 상태와 플러스 상태 사이에서 무작위로 선택하는 경우인데, 계산한 것처럼 밀도 행렬이
이런 형태예요. 0 상태와 플러스 상태는 직교하지 않아서 이건
스펙트럼 분해가 아니에요. 하지만 이런 경우 컴퓨터나 손으로 스펙트럼 분해를 계산하면,
밀도 행렬을 이렇게 표현할 수 있어요. 고유값은 계속 나오는 이 숫자들이고,
해당하는 고유 벡터는 화면 아래에 나타난 것처럼 선택할 수 있어요. 이 벡터들은 이전에 본 적 있어요. 예를 들어
4번 수업의 CHSH 게임 맥락에서요. 흥미롭죠. 원래 표현에 따르면 이 상태는 0 상태와
플러스 상태 두 가지 중에서 균일하게 선택해서 얻는 거예요. 하지만 실제로 두 순수 상태 중에서 무작위로 선택해도
정확히 같은 밀도 행렬을 얻어요. 단, 하나 쪽으로 아주 강하게 편향되어 있어요. 첫 번째 쪽으로 약 85%, 두 번째 쪽으로는 약 15%만요.
그래서 어떤 의미에서는 상태에 내재된 무작위성이 원래 보였던 것보다
실제로 훨씬 적어요. 단일 qubit의 양자 상태를 생각하고 시각화하는 아주 멋진 기하학적 방법이 있는데,
Bloch 구라고 해요. 이건 단일 qubit에만 작동해요. 두 개 이상의 고전적 상태를 가진 시스템,
즉 두 개 이상의 qubit이 함께 있는 경우에는 더 이상 작동하지 않아요. 꽤 제한적이지만,
그래도 단일 qubit의 상태를 생각하는 아주 좋은 방법이에요. 시리즈의 첫 번째 수업에서
이미 소개될 수도 있었지만, 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하는 데 꼭 필수적인 건 아니고, 밀도 행렬과 아주 멋진
연결 관계가 있기 때문에 이 수업에 자연스럽게 맞아떨어져요. 실제로 밀도 행렬을 사용해서
효과적으로 유도하는 방식으로 조금 다르게 설명할 거예요. 이미 Bloch 구에 익숙하다면 이 설명이
처음 배운 방식과 조금 다를 수 있지만, 결국에는 물론 동등할 거예요. 먼저 qubit의 가능한 순수 상태에 대해
양자 상태 벡터로 표현된 것을 생각해 볼게요.
전역 위상까지 모든 qubit 양자 상태 벡터는 화면에 나타난 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
정확히 말하면, 두 실수 θ와 φ가 있는데, 이 두 숫자를 라디안으로 표현된 각도로 생각할 거예요.
첫 번째 숫자 θ는 0과 π 사이에 있어요. 동치로 말하면, 0도와 180도 사이의 각도예요.
두 번째 숫자 φ는 0과 2π 사이에 있는데, 0은 포함하고 2π는
포함하지 않아요. 그래서 0도와 360도 사이의 어떤 각도든 돼요. 벡터의 0번째 원소는
θ/2의 코사인이에요. 그래서 0과 1 사이의 실수이고, 특히 반드시 음이 아니에요.
그리고 벡터의 1번째 원소는 e^(iφ) × sin(θ/2)이고, 그건 복소 단위원 위나 안에 있는 어떤 복소수든 될 수 있어요.
이건 항상 단위 벡터이고, 즉 유효한 양자 상태 벡터예요. 주어진 qubit 양자 상태 벡터에 대해
항상 전역 위상까지 그 벡터와 동치인 이 형태의 벡터를 찾을 수 있어요.
특히, 주어진 벡터에 전역 위상을 곱해서 0번째 원소를 음이 아닌 실수로 만들 수 있어요. 그 원소를 주는
θ를 선택하고, 그 다음 1번째 원소와 일치하는 φ를 선택하면 돼요. 1번째 원소의 크기는
단위 벡터로 시작했다는 가정에 의해 항상 θ/2의 사인과 일치해요.
이제 θ와 φ가 시작한 양자 상태 벡터에 의해 유일하게 결정되지는 않아요.
하지만 거의 그래요. 작동하는 0과 π 사이의 유일한 θ 값은 항상 있어요.
그리고 보통 작동하는 유일한 φ 값이 있지만, 두 가지 특수한 경우에는 그렇지 않아요.
특히, 표준 기저 상태에서 시작하면 θ가 0 또는 π가 되는데, 두 경우 모두 φ가 실제로 무엇인지 중요하지 않아요.
완전히 무관해요. θ가 0이면 θ/2의 코사인은 1이고 θ/2의 사인은
0이에요. 그래서 e^(iφ)에 0을 곱하니까 φ가 무엇이든 차이가 없어요.
θ가 π이면 이번에는 코사인이 0이고 사인이 1이에요. 따라서 e^(iφ) × |1⟩인데, 이 벡터들은 모두 전역 위상까지 동치예요.
그러므로 다시 한 번 φ가 무엇인지 중요하지 않아요. 하지만 θ가 0과 π 사이에 진정으로 있다면,
항상 작동하는 유일한 φ 값이 있어요. 그런데 두 특수한 경우에 φ 값의 가능한 이 퇴화는
잠시 후 기하학적 그림을 보면 완벽하게 이해가 될 거예요.
이제 방금 확인한 형태의 상태 벡터와 관련된 밀도 행렬을 계산해 볼게요.
이건 qubit의 순수 상태예요. 이를 위해 평소대로 벡터를 켤레 전치와 곱해요.
화면에는 켤레 전치를 계산하고 곱셈을 수행해서 얻는 행렬의 식이 있어요.
모든 2×2 행렬처럼, Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 이 행렬을 얻는 유일한 방법이 있어요.
항등 행렬을 포함해서요. 특히 화면에 나타난 것처럼 Pauli 행렬의 계수를 선택해서 이 행렬을 얻을 수 있어요.
분모에 2를 넣는 건 모든 게 멋지게 정리되기 때문이에요. 이렇게 해야 하는 건 아니지만, 할 수 있고 도움이 돼요.
하지만 이 외관상의 선택을 제외하면 다른 선택의 여지가 없어요. 이게 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 이 행렬을 얻는 유일한 방법이에요.
항등 행렬을 포함한 Pauli 행렬들이 모든 2×2 행렬의 벡터 공간에 대한 기저이기 때문이에요.
이 식의 정확성을 확인하는 한 가지 방법은 기본적인 삼각 함수 항등식을 사용하는 거예요. 특히 제가 잠깐 비켜서면
여기 도움이 될 몇 가지 항등식이 있어요. 원하시면 영상을 일시 정지하거나
스크린샷을 찍고, 첫 번째 밀도 행렬 식에서 아래쪽 두 번째 식을 유도할 수 있는지 확인해 보세요.
요약하면, 밀도 행렬로 표현된 qubit의 순수 상태는 화면에 나타난 것처럼 Pauli 행렬의 선형 결합으로 쓸 수 있어요.